unser kollege teilweise der moderator
von die richtigen fragen hatte eben die
möglichkeit mit spd-parteichef lars
klingbeil zu sprechen und er hat ihn
auch auf die mutige protestaktion von
marina ob sie an ecover angesprochen
dieser mutigen beeindruckenden frau mit
der wir gerade hatten sprechen können
die beiden haben in erster linie
natürlich über die ukraine gesprochen
über putins krieg aber auch über
klingbeil neuen job beim fc bayern
münchen hier ist da ein spezial von die
richtigen fragen
[Musik]
bild die richtigen fragen an lars
klingbeil den spd-vorsitzenden herzlich
willkommen bei bild schulter was kann
diesen schrecklichen krieg ihrer meinung
nach beenden es sind viele sachen die
zusammenkommen ist gibt erstmal ein
widerstand der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer selbst den ich bewundere und
der mit dem viele nicht gerechnet haben
ich glaube das bringt doch wladimir
putin zum nachdenken und wir sehen dass
die russische armee nicht in dem zustand
ist den herr putin sich glaube ich schön
geredet hat über über jahre auch in den
letzten monaten wir haben ein
geschlossenes bündnis im westen dass
waffen liefert das harte sanktionspaket
durchsetzt dass politischen druck macht
und es kommt jetzt ganz zentral auch auf
china an wo ja auch das westliche
bündnis in gesprächen ist aber auch
deutlich macht welche erwartungen es
gibt und das sind alles punkte die
hoffentlich dazu beitragen dass wladimir
putin schnell nachgibt und von seinem
also als schlächter putin geschwächtes
russland militärisch auch stark
geschwächtes russland das ist ihr
szenario für ein ende dieses krieg ist
ein normales geht um dass die
militärische schwäche der russlands es
geht um die stärke auch der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer es geht um
das geschlossene bündnis des westens es
geht um den ökonomischen druck das sind
alles faktoren die zusammenspielen und
es läuft nicht so wie putin sich das
vorgestellt hat das ist erstmal das ist
erstmal gut in diesen tag trotzdem
erleben wir jeden tag diesen brutalen
krieg die brutalen bilder und ich glaube
wir alle hoffen dass es sehr schnell zu
einem ende kommt muss putin weg ich
glaube dass dieser krieg das ende von
putin eingeläutet hat und dass auch der
rückhalt so sind die informationen die
ich bekomme auch öffentliche
informationen der rückhalt in seiner
eigenen regierung in den
sicherheitsapparat der fängt er an zu
bröckeln ich glaube dass putin sich
konzentriert auf ganz wenige berater
dass er leute um sich rum sammelt die ja
sager sind und dass er nochmal er hat
sein land über jahre isoliert was muss
er weg also das wäre eine ganz klare
festlegung darauf dass das eine lösung
dieses krieges wer putin weg erst mal
muss das brutale morden in der ukraine
sofort gestorben das hat damit nicht und
das und das nochmal die politischen
prozesse in russland die werden sehr
schnell auch an dynamik gewinnen wenn
putin ihren frage gestellt wird er führt
sein land sein eigenes land gerade uns
unglück ins ökonomische unglück r14 die
in die welt politische isolierung es
gibt es gab in der abstimmung im un
sicherheitsrat gab es noch vier
diktaturen die mit russland gemeinsam
gestimmt haben russland wo sich vorher
viele bemüht haben es in die
weltgemeinschaft reinzuholen ist völlig
ammerland und lasuren auswirkungen auf
die politische zukunft von wladimir
putin haben ich hoffe dass sie sehr
schnell zu ende geht aber das wird in
russland entschieden der sieg über das
was dazu beitragen ist noch etwas dazu
bei auf weiß nicht was ich nicht sehe er
weise ist dass wir irgendwann wieder in
einem normalen verhältnis mit wladimir
putin an tischen sitzen werden dass wir
gespräche führen werden diese zeit ist
vorbei so normal wie das bisher schon
war an dem langen tisch zu sitzen mit
wladimir putins gab ja auch formal
verkürzt kritisch und dem mann gesessen
hat können sie sich vorstellen dass in
den nächsten tagen eine situation
eintritt in der man sowie das mir in
mario pohl vielleicht ansatzweise schon
passiert der ukraine dann nahe legt
kommt jetzt also wenn das noch
zehntausende opfer erfordert noch
hunderttausende flüchten oder millionen
sogar dann kapituliert doch das ergibt
doch keinen sinn ich glaube dass die
ukrainische regierung heiße lenski dass
die ukrainische bevölkerung da keine
ratschläge braucht das was wir tun
können sind nochmal waffenlieferung
sanktionspaket politischer druck aber
die verhandlungen finden zwischen der
ukraine und russland statt regeln wir
jetzt da an der
kapitulation damit dann irgendwie so ein
schmutziger frieden einkehrt man
irgendein deal macht die gebiete gehen
dann an putin und dann setzt man erst
mal seine unterschrift drunter und
vorübergehend wird eben niemand mehr aus
seinen häusern ausgebombt wenn ich noch
mal das ziel ist doch jetzt dass
zwischen der ukraine und russland die
verhandlungen zu einem waffenstillstand
geführt werden dass es dann sei auch zu
gesprächen kommt aber ich finde da
sollten wir uns zurückhalten mit
ratschlägen die wir der ukrainischen
regierung und exzellenz gegeben was
glauben sie hätten willy brandt helmut
schmidt getan in diesen tagen in diesen
wochen in diesen monaten hätten die
zugeschaut wie vor ihrer haustür ein
demokratisches folgten zusammengebaut
zusammengeschossen wird ich weigere mich
gegen die formulierungen zu schauen weil
das was die bundesregierung die
europäische union die nato
gerade tun und das hat olaf scholz schon
getan als noch gespräche mit wladimir
putin habe ich gesagt tatenlos zuschauen
dazu denn wir sehen jeden tag hier auch
beide live diese schrecklichen bilder
zum beispiel aus mario pohl und am ende
schauen wir zu wie dieses demokratische
volk zusammen gebaut wird und das ist
brutal und das zerreißt ein auch als
mensch als politiker muss man immer in
der lage sein mit kühlem kopf auch
entscheidung zu treffen und sich zu
fragen was bedeutet welcher schritt und
nochmal deswegen ist mir wichtig dass
wir klar machen welche schritte wir alle
gehen sanktionen die auch unser land
betreffen waffenlieferungen die einbruch
sind auch mit mit mit außen-
sicherheits- politischen grundsätzen in
diesem land ein bündnis der nato das
gerade wieder erstarkt der wir haben vor
zwei jahren nicht aus deutschland aber
auch frankreich aus den usa debatten
über das ende der radtour für das sind
alles dinge mit den putin nicht
gerechnet hat jetzt da sind und trotzdem
haben sie natürlich recht dass wir diese
brutalen bilder sehen und man sich als
mensch aber auch als politiker jeden tag
fragt müssen wir eigentlich noch
hermachen schmidt will können wir nach
glaube holt so geschah ich bin der
festen überzeugung dass das was wir
gerade tun die die politik auf der einen
seite den den druck hoch zu fahren und
im bündnis zu stehen
auf der anderen seite sich aber auch zu
fragen welche konsequenzen ziehen wir
jetzt dauerhaft zum beispiel 100
milliarden die wir jetzt in einem
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr auf
den riegel an dass das im geiste auch
von brandt und schmidt ist ich frag
deswegen weil das so schwer zu ertragen
ist diese bilder aus mario pohl und hier
zu sitzen im westen ganz normales leben
zu führen und genauso war es vergangene
woche im bundestag können uns diese rede
noch einmal ansatzweise anschauen von
vladimir selensky es war ein ganz
besondere momente in der vergangenen
woche im bundestag sie haben wahlkampf
gemacht in dem überall respekt darüber
stand und diesen respekt habe ich in den
momenten nicht gespürt wir schauen dass
noch mal die rede von flotter selensky
ihr kanzler olaf scholz dreht sich zu
ihm schaut ihm zuhört ihn zu
findet worte die einem unter die haut
gegangen sind und es gibt danach auch
kurze standing ovations und dann drehen
sich alle wieder um ihr kanzler
eingeschlossen der persönlich
angesprochen wurde von vladimir selenz
'es war das respektvoll es war richtig
dass er im parlament gesprochen hat es
war richtig dass das parlament in gänze
sich erhoben hat es war richtig dass man
sich bei ihm bedankt hat aber es war
falsch wie das parlament in gänze auf
diese rede reagiert hat war das von
ihrem kanzler respektlos nein das war
nicht respektlos
olaf scholz hat sehr klar gesagt dass
diese rede für sich steht sehe ich auch
so diese rede war so beeindruckend dass
sie für sich steht aber wir hätten zeit
nehmen müssen dass sie wirkt und dass
man nicht einfach zur tagesordnung
übergeht und das was olaf scholz macht
als bundeskanzler was er seit wochen
macht diese regierung ist hundert tage
im amt dass man sich auch immer bewusst
machen welch große verantwortung diese
ersten 100 tagen ist dass man an der
seite der ukraine steht dass man immer
wieder in gesprächen mit putin geht dass
man das westliche bündnis das sind alles
dinge die olaf scholz im konkreten tut
um an der seite der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer zu stehen an der seite der
ukrainische regierung wieder stehen und
dort wundert mich in dem moment ein
bisschen über eine floskelhafte antwort
weil das so in diesem moment war ein
blöder selensky nicht ihren
bundeskanzler so persönlich an und ich
habe sie erklingen weil immer anders
erlebt auch in solchen momenten auch
jemand der ganz ehrlich ganz menschlich
reagieren kann das wäre das normalste
von der welt gewesen in dem moment kurz
aufzustehen spontan ein paar worte an
herrn selensky zur aber die meisten sind
dauerhaften gespräch und die beiden sind
im dauerhaften gespräch die beiden
beraten sich eng olaf scholz lässt nie
ein zweifel daran dass er an der seite
auch der ukraine und der ukrainischen
regierung steht aber das war eine
situation in der das parlament herrn
selensky eingeladen hat zu sprechen in
der das parlament falsch reagiert hat in
der das parlament hätte unterbrechen
müssen hier an dieser stelle ging es um
den deutschen bundestag nicht um die
bundesregierung es gab auch andere dinge
die aus der regierung auf ukrainischer
seite als ja nicht besonders respektvoll
wahrgenommen wurden beispielsweise die
ankündigung um 5.000 helme zu liefern
okay das ist schnee von gestern dann
aber auch die tatsache dass offenbar die
waffen in großem umfang nicht angekommen
sind die man versprochen hat und auch
weitestgehend eben alte waffen geliefert
wurden nichts neues interessiert sich
ihre ministerin nicht so dafür
interessiert die sich für diesen krieg
nicht so sehr ich erlebe christine
lambrecht ja in den letzten hundert
tagen in dieser rolle als ministerin und
ich erlebe jeden tag dass sie dafür
wirbt und druck macht das weitere waffen
geliefert werden dass geprüft wird auch
was in der bundeswehr lieferbar ist und
es sind viele dinge geliefert worden es
werden viele sachen geliefert und
glauben sie mal dass nicht alles in der
öffentlichkeit ist auch was geliefert
wird wir müssen auch diejenigen schützen
die liefern es geht darum soldaten und
soldaten die in die ukraine liefern zu
schützen deswegen ist es richtig dass
nicht über alles gesagt ist nötig
gewachsen
und wir haben mit christine lambrecht
eine ministerin an der spitze des
ministeriums die eine top parlamentarier
ihren staatssekretären ministerin auch
in anderen bereichen war die eine starke
führungsperson ist und die und das ist
wichtig jetzt für die neuaufstellung der
bundeswehr eine top juristin ist es geht
um vergaben es geht um die ganzen
prozess und wissen sie
diesen job sehr ist jemand an der spitze
des verteidigungsministeriums
den ersten 100 tagen die in den ersten
100 tagen eine große verantwortung
übernimmt jetzt auf neue weise gefangen
auf räumung mit dingen die in 16 jahren
unions geführten ministerium völlig
gleich offen und ich nehme natürlich war
das in der jetzigen zeit die
konservativen mit einer starken frau an
der spitze des verteidigungsministeriums
ein problem haben aber frau lamprecht
ist eine top ministerin sie will dessen
jockey manchmal wenden kann für sie ist
so schwierigen sie ist diejenige die die
bundeswehr gut führen gut aufstellen
wird und gut in dieser zeit vertritt hat
die spd immer noch ein putin problem
wir haben als partei auch als regierung
in den letzten jahren in der wir
beteiligt waren darauf gesetzt dass wir
mit putin in den wägen die wir über
jahre ja auch verinnerlicht haben
völkerrecht diplomatie gespräche dass
wir dort lösungen finden und putin hat
uns belogen und das was für mich als
parteivorsitzender ich bin ja seit
september haben sich richtig war war das
ist sofort zum bruch kommt dass es zu
einer kleinen kommt und insofern haben
wir als spd eine klarheit was vielleicht
aber es gibt doch gar kein woche
generalsekretär hat noch im januar
gesagt dass man jetzt nord stream mit
diesen blöden konflikte in der ukraine
nicht vermengen dürfe käppis war bei der
fina hat ist ja nach wie vor
generalsekretär generalsekretär sie
haben da ja nicht aufgabe sie haben zur
kenntnis genommen dass natrium 2
gestoppt wurde von dieser
bundesregierung und die spd stellt den
kanzler dieser regierung also sind es
sind sehr konsequent entscheidung
getroffen worden in dem moment wo putin
auch nachweisbar sein gesicht geändert
hat wir haben schon in den verhandlungen
selbst hat olaf scholz sanktionspaket
vorbereitet also an der stelle haben wir
klar uns vorbereitet auf die frage was
passiert wenn putin die grenze
überschreitet aber es war richtig dass
wir verhandelt haben es war richtig dass
wir bis zur letzte friedliche lösung
gesetzt haben aus heutiger sicht muss
man sagen 2008 georgien 2014 aktion der
krim das was in russland passiert ist
die auftragsmorde hier gerade
offensichtlich da war dass man da waren
ist noch richter waren geschafft wo man
aus heutiger sicht sagen muss man hätte
andere schlüsse auch ziehen müssen sogar
das sage ich auch selbstkritisch aber
nochmal die letzte bundesregierung hat
darauf gesetzt sich mit putin einen
tisch zu setzen und ich halte es auch
immer für richtig dass wir den
diplomatischen den friedlichen weg
suchen aber putin hat uns belogen ich
zeige ihnen ein foto das in ukrainischen
kreisen rom geht und das ist eine
fotomontage natürliches zeigt gerd
schröder in russischer militär uniform
mit ganz vielen abzeichen mit medaillen
mit orden dort so sieht man ihn aktuell
wie gesagt ganz klar ein foto mental
montage dass es nicht real aber es steht
ja für etwas wie finden sie das foto
habe ich finde fotomontagen und gefakte
bilder in diesen kriegs
auseinandersetzung falsch und das ist
auch beleidigend einer stelle aber was
doch worauf sie doch hinaus wollen ist
die frage wo steht die spd und die spd
hat sich klar positioniert mit dem
bundeskanzler mit den parteivorsitzenden
mit anderen auch an dieser stelle und
gerhard schröder ist in der spd isoliert
es war ihnen bei sarrazin so wichtig
ihnen auszuschließen und sie haben das
danach ausdrücklich begrüßt so klare
worte fehlen jetzt bei gerhard schröder
und es ist schwer zu verstehen warum man
ihn nicht einfach ausschließt was soll
schlimmer sein als sich von einem
kriegsherrn bezahlen zu lassen also was
soll ein besserer parteiausschluss grund
sein als das müsste ein ganz schnell ist
man muss man ja sagen parteiausschlüsse
haben in deutschland zu recht eine hohe
hürde trotzdem läuft das verfahren
der region hannover aber sie sehr bei
sarrazin und ich habe sehr deutlich
gemacht für die parteispitze dass gerd
schröder isoliert ist dass wir seine
politische position an dieser stelle
überhaupt nicht teilen also das ist ja
die klarheit die ich als
parteivorsitzender geschaffen habe die
auch wichtig ist wir stehen an der seite
der ukrainerinnen und ukrainer wir
verurteilen dass das vladimir putin
macht und ich erwarte dass alle
mitglieder der spd diese position noch
deutlich vertreten positioniert der spd
gegenüber putin gegenüber russland war
in der vergangenheit nicht besonders
mutig eine die das gemacht hat in diesen
tagen marina offs janikowski hat live im
russischen staatsfernsehen in der putin
propaganda tagesschau sozusagen zur
besten sendezeit protestiert gegen putin
gegen den krieg den mann dadurch so
nennen darf diese frau ist heute bei
bild was sagen sie er ich habe das
gesehen auch den abend sofort das ist ja
zigfach geteilt worden und ich kann hier
nur sagen ich bewundere diesen mut ich
bewundere den mut dass sie in russland
aufsteht und wir alle können uns nur
ungefähr vorstellen was das bedeutet und
es ist ja auch nicht russland das den
krieg gegen die ukraine führt es ist
putin mit seinem regime und es gibt
viele viele mutige russinnen und russen
die aufstehen in diesen tagen die sich
während die die deutlich machen dass sie
diesen krieg nicht mittragen und sie
gehört ein prominenter stelle mit dazu
und das verdient unseren respekt die
sich sie ein vorbild auch für unsere
politik für uns alle in deutschland dass
es eben nicht reicht dahin zu gehen wo
es noch nicht weh tut sondern
tatsächlich bis zuletzt für die eigenen
werte einzustehen auch wenn es weh tut
ja ich glaube dass in solchen
situationen auch solche helden dann
deutlich werden und dass man die
brauchen dass wir uns natürlich wünschen
dass in der russischen gesellschaft
viele leute aufstehen viele leute den
mut haben und dafür braucht es solche
vorbilder und und dieses verfahren muss
öffentlich begleitet werden auch damit
klar ist auf die russische führung dass
der druck sehr groß ist dass wir alle
genau hingucken und wir sollten uns
hinter sich stellen angesichts der
grossen themen über die wir gesprochen
haben ist es dann kleingeistig aktuell
über entlastung von autofahrern zu
sprechen nein das ist nicht kleingeistig
sondern das ist eine direkte folge auch
des brutalen angriffs krieges den putin
führt dass hier die energiepreise massiv
steigen dass die gesellschaft damit auch
belastet wird dass ich herausgehobene
immer mehr auch die rückmeldung bekommen
auch aus dem eigenen wahlkreis dass dort
menschen genau gucken müssen ob sie die
nächste tankfüllung noch hinbekommen wie
das mit den heizkosten aussieht das
belastet die menschen und und das ist ja
auch unsere aufgabe als politik den
zusammenhalt in diesem land zu sichern
und deswegen ist es richtig dass die
koalition nach dem ersten
entlastungspaket jetzt in dieser woche
den anspruch hat ein zweites
entlastungspaket auch zu schmieden in
dieser woche zu schmieden wollte man in
der vergangenen woche und in der
vorvergangenen woche auch schon spielen
ich habe das deswegen gefragt mit dem
kleingeistig weil mein eindruck ist dass
es am ende doch hinten runter fällt
irgendwie dass man sich sagt na gut also
die einen fordern dass tank rabatt
christian lindner die anderen wollen
dass energie geld sie sitzen irgendwo
dazwischen mit ihrem bundeskanzler und
es fällt am ende den tisch runter es
gibt dann gar keine entlastung für die
autofahrer dauert schon so lange mein
alle drei parteien haben den festen
willen zu entlasten aber es gehört auch
mit wir haben das schon beweise werden
es mit einem paket im rahmen von 13
milliarden schon getan um 23 februar das
war schossen vor dem krieg beschloss das
ist ein tag vorm genau das wird jetzt
aber umgesetzt die abschaffung
eeg-umlage ja gewinns einmal mehr das
entlastet den folgen des krieges gar
nichts natürlich hat dass da auch schon
damit zu tun gehabt dass die situation
sich angespannt hat wir hatten ja schon
vorher auch die die auseinandersetzung
in der ukraine durch russland also das
gab es ja in diesen tagen auch schon
aber noch mal wir sind jetzt dabei in
dieser woche wird es ein zweites paket
geben das ist das was wir was wir als
koalition wollen da reden jetzt die
fachleute darüber dann wird das
politisch entschieden und diese
entlastung muss diese woche auf den weg
auf den weg gebracht werde es muss in
dieser woche ein sogenanntes laufen weil
sie wissen doch wie politik wie rasieren
gesagt gibt es jetzt auch eine hotline
ist besonders ist eine woche eine
politische verständigung das ist das
ziel das wir als spd haben ich nehme
wahr dass grüne und fdp das auch wollen
und dann wird das umgesetzt aber es gibt
diese woche eine verständigung das ist
das klare signal wir sehen dass die
menschen belasten ist ja mir gar nicht
und wir müssen aber schauen aber sie man
warum gehen wir also einmal juni/juli
wand spürt man dass im geldbeutel das
richtige signal ist wir handeln und das
wird diese regierung diese woche aber
das signal ist nicht angekommen bist ja
das eigentliche es würde ankommen wenn
sie einen zeitrahmen nennen wenn sie
sagen okay aber dann muss auch ein
bisschen weil es auch kompliziert nein
es ist nicht wollen halt weiter streiten
immer miteinander da weiß man gar nicht
wie man die zusammenbringen soll
deswegen dauert es im moment so lange
aber ich verspreche ihnen im juni spüren
sie es im geldbeutel dass wir klar das
paket muss diese woche auf den weg
gebracht werden und die entlastung muss
so schnell wie möglich da sein aber wir
werden doch jetzt erst mal von den
fachleuten vorschläge bekommen welche
welche maßnahmen das sind und da kann
ich ihnen heute nicht sagen die
maßnahmen die ich noch nicht kenne
greifen dann und das muss auch einmal in
gang bringen und die fahrweise das ist
das richtige signal ist diese regierung
handelt diese regierung es kommt
irgendwann und bürger nicht im stich und
das wird ankommen ob ich sie überzeugte
weiß ich nicht aber meine zielgruppe
sind die bürgerinnen und bürger und die
sehen dass diese regierung handelt ich
möchte ihnen noch robert habeck zeigen
der den bückling gemacht hat vor dem
emir von katar ganz klar warum wir
wollen von putins gas abhängig machen
und jetzt trotzdem irritiert dass viele
deutsche dass man sich verneigt eben
jetzt vor dem nächsten schreckensregime
sag ich einmal muss man manchmal wenn
man regiert ganz einfach die moral zur
seite legen ist das ganz einfach so
gehört das zur ehrlichkeit dazu man muss
schwierige entscheidungen treffen das
ist das wofür wir gewählt wo er in der
verantwortung sind und robert habeck hat
das sehr gut beschrieben auch in welcher
in welchem dilemma muss als zuständiger
minister als organisieren dass wir
ausreichend energie haben dass hier
nicht die arbeitslosigkeit hoch geht
dass die wirtschaft weiter funktionieren
kann dass der wohlstand in deutschland
auch organe muss man mal dass das
handeln und deswegen jetzt gilt es drum
manchmal auch entscheidungen zu treffen
die nicht überall zu jubeln und zu
beifall fühlen aber es ist doch richtig
dass wir das gemeinsame ziel in der
politik haben ja dass wir rauskommen aus
der unabhängige aus der abhängigkeit von
russischen von russischer energie und da
sucht der minister jetzt nach den besten
wegen das ist auch sein job was klar ist
ist wir müssen mit einer riesen
geschwindigkeit raus aus den fossilen
energieträgern das haben wir im
koalitionsvertrag zur note sage lasst
uns das noch schneller machen aber wir
setzen an dieser stelle in der tat das
ist der vorschlag des ministers of
energy gas und dafür führt er jetzt
gespräch lieber das gas als die moral
muss man beim fc bayern manchmal auch
unmoralische deals machen steht man ja
einen selben dilemma man möchte auch das
geld von katar und die sprich sie
deswegen auf den fc bayern an weil sie
dort jetzt im verwaltungsbeirat sitzen
herzlich willkommen und herzlichen
glückwunsch für diesen offiziellen job
dort beim fc bayern hier sehen wir sie
einmal an der seite von paul breitner
aus ja schon ein bisschen ich schon
bisschen
muss man auch da manchmal um moralische
entscheidungen machen also sind sie für
den nächsten katja diehl ich glaube wir
müssen offen beschreiben in welchem
dilemma dass man noch ist das hat robert
habeck getan als er da war und wissen
sie alle haben auch dass ich freue mich
über das engagement und das vertrauen
das ich von bayern münchen habe aber
natürlich geht es auch da im verein und
das hat man auf der letzten
jahreshauptversammlung gesehen das gebot
darum genau an dieser stelle zu
diskutieren abzuwägen was sind die
nächsten schritte und ich werde mich
dazu im verein engagieren es wird
sicherlich diese debatte auch auf mich
zukommen und ich erwarte dass ein verein
so was auch offen diskutiert die fans
und der sturm gelaufen sind sie an der
stelle von oder funktionär ich würde mir
dieses geschenk das man gucken wie sie
im verein läuft und nicht von außen ins
ratschläge geben ich bin gestern berufen
worden und jetzt werde ich mir sie haben
wir als verein auch noch keine position
dazu ich glaube das ist richtig ist dass
wir aus allen regime die
nicht unsere werte vertreten dass wir
mit denen unabhängig also dass wir
unabhängig von den sind das haben wir
gerade bei russland schmerzlich erfahren
ich habe mich gerade im interview auch
im spiegel dazu geäußert dass ich der
meinung bin wir müssen aus einer
abhängigkeit die wir von china haben
auch und es kommen wir müssen heute
schon sehen welche probleme gibt es aber
noch mal bei energie ist es so dass wir
wissen der ausweg aus diesem dilemma ist
der radikale ausbau erneuerbarer
energien aber wir wissen auch dass
schaffen wenn ich in den nächsten zwölf
monaten spd-chef und fc bayern
verwaltungsbeirat spd und fcb passt für
viele nicht so richtig zusammen sie
vereinen die beiden partei und
champions-league-sieger
wenn sie sagen müssten für welchen
welche mitgliedschaft sie mehr chips
turms bekommen was antworten sie ich
habe bisher für keine mitgliedschaften
und zukunft meint er kein bewusster
weiterhin als cd beides sehr beliebte
organisation auch nicht im freundeskreis
muss dass wenn ein sich hat sich sehr
gewandelt aber ich also noch mal ich
freue mich dass ich in beiden aktiv sein
kann dass ich in beiden verantwortung
trage beides sind rote und das passt
jetzt legen sie sich einmal fest noch
zum schluss sie müssen sich entscheiden
zwischen champions league sieg hier oder
saarland sieg hier bei der spd ist
beides
die cdu hat ja gestern die saarland wahl
aufgegeben der der generalsekretär auf
bundesebene hat erklärt wir werden uns
sehr engagieren also das ist das läuft
das er sei genutzt worden und jetzt ich
habe gestern da und jetzt geht es am
sonntag darum dass wir die saarland wahl
gewinnen ich bin guter job oder herz als
anke rehlinger das schafft ich
entscheide mich immer sozusagen für die
roten sehr geschickt der mann der immer
überall gewinnen will lars klingbeil der
spd-vorsitzende hierbei bild dagegen
dankeschön